(crowd applause)
- All right, everybody.
We're back with Randy
Jackson and Kate Walsh.
Give it up.
(crowd applause)
Well, since he first entered the pros,
our next guest has been considered one
of the greatest lacrosse
players on the planet.
Bur bur bur bur,
(audience laughs)
He's also known as a huge
rebel within the sport,
which is super fun.
After 10 years in Major League Lacrosse,
he was appalled with the way
players were being treated.
So in 2018, he and his brother
took on the establishment.
They created a new league
that promised better pay,
better conditions, even health benefits.
His ambitious, often emotional
journey was documented
in the new film co-produced
by LeBron James.
Never heard of him.
(audience laughter)
Fate of a Sport.
(intense music)
- Starting a professional
sports league is impossible.
- On the field-
You shouldn't be standing
for this (bleep).
- I don't see them doing a deal with us.
- It's hard for me to
imagine what it would be
like to both be a commissioner
and play in the NBA.
- I know he's got a lot on his
plate, you know what I mean?
(players chanting)
You're running a league,
you're trying to win a championship,
and you're trying to
perform as an individual
- How (bleep) hard is that?
(swoosh)
(audience applause)
- That's co-founder of the
Premier Lacrosse League,
a National and International
Lacrosse Champion,
Paul Rabil.
Give it up.
(audience applause)
- Thank you.
- Well, first of all, meet Randy.
Meet Kate.
- Hey, guys.
- Hello. (laughs)
- Such a pleasure.
- Dude, nice to meet you.
Great sport, Lacrosse.
- Thank you. Thank you. Appreciate that.
- Tough.
- It is a tough sport.
So tell us, tell us more about
why you wanted to launch
a new lacrosse league.
- Well, actually tough,
In the late 1960s, Sports
Illustrated had lacrosse
on the cover, and they
called it the tough game.
But, well, well before that,
it was a Native American game.
It's actually the first sport
in North American history.
It was created by the
Haudenosaunee people.
It was called-
- What?
- Deyhontsigwa'ehs, which
means "they bump hips,"
And it was created to celebrate
and honor the creator.
The version that we see
today is the secular version
and it's the game that
was once in the Olympics.
Fast forward to me growing up in the 90's
and playing in 2000's, it just no longer
had those roots or that
purpose or that soul.
And as I played for 12 years in the pros
formerly with Major League
Lacrosse, my wage was $8,000.
We had no marketing, we
had no network partner,
and I was just feeling like the
sport shouldn't be this way.
And you saw MLS, UFC, F1.
Now, we all watched them at the time,
but they were on the same journey.
So if you take on the internet,
modern media and stuff,
those new leagues have since emerged.
And I felt like lacrosse could do that.
So I partnered with my brother.
We took on the establishment.
It was a hell of a ride, and
it brought me here today.
- Wow.
(audience applause)
- That is incredible.
I did not know the, like,
origin story of lacrosse.
It's really cool.
I did not know that.
And I will be googling that afterwards.
- So cool.
- Cause I'm-
- I did my job here then.
- Yeah
(laughs)
- We are gonna go away and study.
Well, starting a new
professional sports league
that can't be like a small
task, that's daunting.
- Yeah, there were two things really.
So my brother and I, who
is my co-founder of the PLL
we have major imposter syndrome.
I think, you know, a lot
of people may be able to relate to that.
You have that as an athlete.
- Yeah.
- And then build that over the top of
there was already a league that we were
ultimately fighting against.
- Yeah.
- So there were lawsuits
over top of even, you know
signing players, building
teams, getting venues done,
legal, marketing, promotion,
all this stuff that
neither my brother and I
had a background in sports.
So we were taken on for the
first time and then we launched
and then Major League Lacrosse
came back to us and said,
"All right, you've done that.
Now we're ready to buy you."
And they offered us $35
million for the league
which Mike and I had never
seen anything like that.
- Well, that's a lot of money.
(laughs)
Yeah.
- [Kate] It's a lot of money.
- That's hard to, to pass on.
It's a lot of shoes.
- Yeah. (laughs)
- I wish I had the gumption to sort of get
on the phone and say, "It's
gonna be a no for me, dawg."
- Yeah. (laughs)
- Oh, look at him.
Look at him, Kel, Look
at him, look at him.
(laughing)
Oh my God, I use that GIF all the time!
- That was less, I was less smooth.
I was less smooth than that.
I was less smooth.
But, we knew, we knew
that it wasn't, you know
while there would've
been a short-term payoff,
our mission was to not
just build a better future
for lacrosse players, but
realign the game with its roots.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Randy] Love that.
- But you just started a program
called Goals for Greatness.
So what is this about?
- Yeah, so this is sort
of outside of the PLL.
I just announced my retirement
a couple of years ago.
Trying to play and build
the league was just too much
of a conflict for me personally.
And I thought about ways that lacrosse
could potentially reach new people
and we can visually see it.
So what I committed to do in
Goals for Greatness is to put goals
and fields in all 50 states every year.
I started it last year.
So we contributed goals to all 50 states.
We host free clinics
for our program partners
that we work with as you can see here.
Our first one was with Compton
Lacrosse here in California.
That was last March.
And as we start 2023,
we just notified Oakland
Lacrosse earlier today
in the Bay Area that we're
gonna contribute 10 goals
to their program.
So we're gonna start in California
and then we're gonna go hopefully
in future years internationally.
(audience applause)
- Great.
- [Kelly] That's so cool. Opportunity-
- Nice.
- It's such an important thing.
I literally, I was involved in the arts
and the athletic programs
and it's so important
even to get the endorphins,
you know, everything going.
It's so beneficial.
- Yeah. I think the values that we get
from sports or the arts,
and I've had my own journey
with my competitive nature,
I would venture to say that
none of you three would be here
if you weren't supreme competitors.
- I'm competitive.
(laughs)
- I would bet.
- In a healthy way.
- In a way, I'm, I am.
I'm not about, but when it comes
to, remember, when it comes
to work, I'd be like, why are
all these other people here
for my role?
- Right, exactly.
- You know what I mean?
(laughs)
(claps)
(audience laughs)
- It was was like almost sociopathic,
but I literally I was like,
- (laughs) Sounds like you had
a healthy relationship, yeah.
"Why are they signed in on the,
you know we used to audition."
- How dare you.
- [Kate] Yeah, yeah.
Why are you here?
Sorry, guys.
Go home.
I got this.
(audience laughs)
- But I think when you
start out, to me, Louisiana
you want to be the best.
- [Paul] Yeah.
- You want to shoot for the top, top, top.
All of you.
All of us.
- Yeah.
- That's what we did.
- Yeah, we're very lucky.
- Thank you so much, Paul.
- My pleasure.
I loved all the information.
It's powerful.
(audience applause)
- Thank you.
- Fate of a Sport is streaming
now on Hulu and ESPN.